i'm michaela peterson welcome to my
channel
so i realize this is probably a few days
late but i've been
really busy making merch why you might
ask
well marvel i honestly love marvel
usually
i'm obsessed with superheroes turned the
red skull into my dad
less nerdy folks might recognize the red
skull from captain america number one
the winter soldier as literally the evil
nazi super villain
let me repeat a super villain nazi comic
book character
i've been called a nazi before it's not
pleasant but this is
one step beyond that i mean nazi
apparently isn't enough i have to be a
magical super nazi
by implication well really it's so it's
so
it's so surreal and absurd that that i
couldn't believe it to begin with
dad tweeted it out a few days ago
honestly i think it took me a day to
actually believe it was real
i thought maybe my dad was reading too
far into this
uh my dad can't be written into a marvel
comic as a super villain nazi that just
like what reality am i in maybe it's a
mistake maybe it's photoshop
so i bought the comic online and looked
at it
the red skull ten rules for life okay
that's a little weird
then next to it they have chaos in order
which is literally what my dad has
written about in all three of his books
and the feminist trap which is something
he said and mixed in there is carl lugar
who is literally an anti-semite that
influenced hitler
so just mix them in there with what my
dad actually says cool
then the good guys go on to say it's the
same for all of them
young men weak looking for purpose they
found the skull
he tells them what they've always longed
to hear that they're secretly great
that the whole world is against them
that if they're truly men they'll fight
back
so that's weird anyways as soon as i
read it i was like
okay we can use this merge time
i'm still currently working on pouting
barbie merch from the times fiasco
it's coming but because i'm running my
dad's business and have more serious
things to do it's kind of on the back
burner
but i jumped on this faster being
compared to a nazi is a little bit more
serious
memes have been circulating like mad
here are some good ones
kudos to these people for making these
thank goodness the internet has a sense
of humor some of these are pretty funny
because of the juxtaposition between how
evil the red skull is and what my dad is
like
which is not evil at all
don't don't get bangs there are even
some videos out now
[Music]
you don't have one of those do you
straighten up what you can straighten up
organize your local landscape schedule
your time
start taking control of yourself
clean up your room
you don't have to you don't have to do
any of this
that's okay and how come you're running
anyway like i said i jumped on it we
contacted this kid carl timmlin on
twitter
who had randomly made an awesome lobster
mixed with hydra
hydra's the red skull symbol for his
group of nazis just to be clear
i don't find the fact that my dad was
likened to a nazi super villain funny
my dad has spent the last 30 years
focused on teaching and warning people
against totalitarian ideologies like
nazism
the fact that marvel is okay modeling
the red skull after someone like my dad
in a comic aimed at teenagers is
literally propaganda
tanahasi coates the writer of this comic
is a pretty successful writer
he's written black panther and used to
work for the atlantic
now my dad has critiqued some of his
work and for all i know he wrote it in
there as a joke and his cackling just as
i've been cackling for the last few days
however likening someone to a nazi and
then selling it to kids isn't really
that funny
especially in a comic book aimed at kids
and if you look at the mainstream
media's response
which was massive almost all of them
except the national post
and rex murphy straight up lied about
this
jordan peterson shocked by captain
america
villain red skull espousing 10 rules for
life
jordan peterson is upset that a nazi in
a captain america comic
shares his ideas like what
clean your room take responsibility for
your life
the memes do it better than i my dad was
not happy
in his words it was surreal but don't
give me the
jordan peterson's ideas are like red
skulls
just don't and to assume your readers
are that stupid
is losing you guys readers dad wasn't
angry but shocked was right hell i was
shocked i thought it was photoshopped
and i bought
the comic i gave money to marvel
although
in all fairness i'm probably going to go
to the movies
still and watch those because i like
them but this is too weird
mainstream media acts like there's a
tiny minority of disaffected people
following my dad
he's sold six million books he has three
million youtube subscribers
it's like everyone who likes to like
becomes a journalist
that is my dad's quote so i'll give
credit where credit is
due anyway there wasn't much anger
especially not from me
i pretty much immediately thought that
this this was so insane it was hilarious
if a bunch of memes come out and you
make merch and donate the proceeds to
charity
then it turns out it's quite funny i
worked with my team
pretty much non-stop for the last few
days particularly my social guide ben
and my brother julian to get this out in
time so thanks to them
thanks to carl gustav timlin for the
lobster logo
thanks to ben for nitpicking the design
with me for like six hours and
sending memes and if anyone wants a
limited edition
hail lobster merchandise a direct play
on the hale hydra from red skull
thanks again it's available it's linked
below
the merch is awesome and proceeds go to
charity
i can't thank people enough for their
support once again we've made over fifty
thousand dollars in profits
i figured out how to monetize social
justice warriors
[Laughter]
and like i said a hundred percent is
going towards a charity in the states
and one in canada focused on helping
families and kids
that was dad's idea every time there's a
controversy like this
i'm making merch beware like i said at
the end of the times video
don't [ __ ] with me or my family
the stone demands a sacrifice
of what clean up your room that's a good
start
organize your local landscape schedule
your time
start taking control of yourself see if
you can stop
saying things you know to be lies